aujourd'hui tv 60,18 vous emmène à la
découverte de risa 6 créé une société
événementielle spécialisée dans le rétro
gaming et du coup ça va être l'occasion
pour nous était de ceux des pièces avec
un site et un autre des filles de la
rédac un autre journaliste alors part
favorite mais bon on va tout donner un
verrat je pense qu'on était tous les
deux trop jeunes pour certains jeux qui
on va essayer aujourd'hui mais du coup
avant d'ajuster découvrir un peu plus
les faits leurs produits
le retro gaming c'est le plaisir de
jouer à des jeux vidéo anciens donc les
tout premiers jeux vidéo les années 80
les années 90 les grands classiques
comme pacman space invaders tetris c'est
vraiment le l'effet nostalgie madeleine
de proust qui qui fonctionne à plein
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mathilde bixente je vais vous faire
goûter aux sports électroniques rétro le
retro gaming esport expérience donc avec
un défi sur tetris ou vous allez devoir
faire le meilleur score et puis le
second défi ce sera sur space invaders
ou là il faudrait est le ou la plus
rapide pour terminer le premier niveau
[Musique]
comment s'en sort là c'est maintient
pour l'instant
se bagarrent ce maillard
un début assez assez difficile à prendre
la mesure de la vitesse de descendre des
pièces du tetris
déjà encline complété c'est pas si mal
bon très très dur vicente
[Musique]
j'ai pas mal de grandes barres droites
ça m'aide pour m'organiser
tabou ligne de me battre
accélère
[Musique]
j'ai chuté de pas mal on rapprocher de
la nsa l'idée
[Musique]
très cher
notamment on est très proche en taille
et en vain les mavs être un match nul au
lit quand et comment est ce qu'on peut
faire pour se départager bon côté
bixente mathilde je vous propose de vous
départager par un quiz
donc il y en a plusieurs qui lui sont
proposés mais votre jeune âge je vous
propose des années 90 ok on va se parler
allez
oui
il mais moi
et bien voilà le défi est terminé du
coup je rends
ma défaite à une adversaire redoutable
certaines femmes je sais pas c'était
serré s'est affairé à une question pré
départ des noms c'est mathilde qui s'est
détaché après l'appel au bruit j'ai donc
le plaisir de lui offrir ses petits
goodies merci beaucoup
merci le petit maillot avec l'étoile
chance et puis pas comme l'autre
constellation un blog si gentil bobby
qui je pourrais écrire les questions du
coup dessus et qu'est ce qu'on fait dans
lequel j'ai échoué voilà pour revenir
plus fort réviser pour la prochaine fois
en tout cas merci beaucoup c'est bassin
nous avoir reçus c'est un bel accueil je
vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]